MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So let's start again.
So Alex is in this room to
talk with us about GAE
Simpleauth, the library he has
been doing to [INAUDIBLE]
App Engine.
So first, Alex, can you
tell me a little
bit more about you.
Who are you?
Where are you based?
What are you working on?
ALEX VAGIN: All right.
So I'm Alex Vagin.
I worked at the University of
Trento for several years,
managing internal infrastructure
and developing
in-house applications.
And just recently, I left that
job to work on my own startup
with a couple of other guys.
And we call it Cloudware.
So the University of Trento--
so this is where I've been
living for the past 10 years.
Though I'm not Italian.
I was born in Ukraine.
And I still have Ukrainian
citizenship.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So you are a Ukrainian based
in Italy who works on
[INAUDIBLE]
a startup.
And so when you start
using App Engine?
And what are you using
App Engine for now?
ALEX VAGIN: So I did have a look
at it when you guys just
announced it--
I think it was in 2008.
But at the time, I didn't have
really time to start
playing with it.
So I kept watching it.
And I think it was a year after,
I started using it for
real, writing some
applications.
Well, a couple of applications
that are are still running.
One of the applications
that I liked it a lot.
It was my last project while
I was working at the
University of Trento.
And it was a website for a local
event that's was called
[? ICD Days. ?]
And so it wasn't just
the website.
It had a few registration
forms.
And it also had N RSVP
thing for the PhD.
And it also had an admin
part, like a little
CMS or whatever system.
And all of those registration
data--
they were being synchronized
with Google Spreadsheets in
the background.
And the funny thing is all of
this stuff up until today,
this website is running
on a free app quota.
And it was kind of funny.
Because the day before the event
really even started, I
was watching the free
instance average
quota going like crazy.
So I did some calculations
beforehand, kind of
approximating.
So I was 75% sure it shouldn't
be going over quota.
But I did have my mouse button
on the Enable Bidding button.
But I just wanted to experiment
and see if I could
really manage to run on
a free app quota.
And it did.
It went--
I don't know--
98%.
But it stayed there.
MALE SPEAKER: And did you use
some tricks in order to
diminish your instantiate
usage?
Or did you rely more
on caching?
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, yeah.
So we basically started
from scratch.
And at the beginning, I was
using NDB and just [INAUDIBLE]
with Data Store directly.
But then as the traffic was
increasing, I realized that I
should add some caching
and stuff.
And so I did.
And yeah.
It did decrease the
instance service.
And what's probably the most
piece of instance hours that
was taken away, it was by these
background processes
that were calling spreadsheet
API's.
Because it's an external API.
So it takes much more time
to interact with.
So what I found out is
that I moved that
part to the back end.
And that was awesome.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
for back end.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
There was one day I realized,
wow, I ought
to have a back end.
So why wouldn't I move
it to the back end?
MALE SPEAKER: And I always have
a lot of people who are
doing that.
Because that's a really
convenient way to scale back
on [? test. ?]
That's just an external
[INAUDIBLE].
But you should definitely target
all your [? SQ ?] work
if you have the free app
to the back end.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, yeah,
definitely yeah.
And I think I don't know.
I mean, I can only speculate.
But it really felt like when
I moved this external API
calling to the back
end or you can
different version or whatever--
so the average of the response
time or latency--
it was kind of like the maximum
and the minimum--
they were reduced, right?
So I think it really helped the
scheduler not to launch
the many instances or stay
up to the right job.
MALE SPEAKER: It depends
on the configuration
of your back end.
But basically the [INAUDIBLE]
for back end is much more
simpler since you get to
control the number of instances
that are running at
a moment of time.
And so [INAUDIBLE]
schedular to take for scheduling
things on back end
is much more simpler.
And plus since it's
not [INAUDIBLE]
with user traffic, the scheduler
can already predict
what will happen.
Because basically all this back
end what will it receive
is internal [? code ?]
from task queues.
And if it's not a [INAUDIBLE]
back end, it's easier for one
to do the scheduling.
ALEX VAGIN: Exactly.
Yeah.
That's what it felt like.
When I moved the not user facing
requests to the back
end, this is what actually
happened.
So the whole response
time for users--
it suddenly decreased.
And it was pretty fast.
MALE SPEAKER: When [INAUDIBLE]
test queue what happened is that
your test queue traffic
is competing with your
user traffic.
And the scheduler will always
[? route ?] to privileged user
traffic first.
So when you are on the
back end you are not
competing with anyone.
ALEX VAGIN: Right.
Yeah, exactly.
MALE SPEAKER: Your observation
was right.
ALEX VAGIN: So yeah.
I was pretty happy about that.
Yeah.
So basically it ran on 24 hours,
3/4, for front end, and
8 hours of back end.
So that was awesome, yeah.
I do have a couple of other
business-wise websites.
One is--
it's a website for a
local restaurant.
But it's not just
static pages.
They offer online orders.
And the owner of the restaurant,
I built for them
this admin interface where they
can add dishes and stuff
and prices.
They also accept payments
with credit cards.
And it's all running
on App Engine.
And this app was running--
I think today it's 12
months, one year.
And it was like the best
experience I ever had.
Because even in the worst days
when App Engine [INAUDIBLE] on
the infrastructure had some
maybe bad days or something, I
never had problem with
this website.
It was great.
AMY: And your company
just launched
something, didn't you?
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, exactly.
And so the biggest project
is yet to come--
so the thing that we launched
is the startup.
It's an app.
It's software as a service.
We call it PhD Hub.
So it basically helps--
there's a PhD school.
And there's administrative
stuff.
And from my previous experience
working at the
University, I found a real
need for some kind of
management software or service
that would help the secretary
and administrative staff
organize all the students,
professors, grades,
or whatever.
And the thing is, I started
running this app
maybe a year ago.
And at the time, when I started,
I didn't have Python
runtime or Java on the
infrastructure where I was
running it.
So initially I wrote it
in Ruby on Rails.
And then in these few months,
I actually started rewriting
it in Python.
So we're slowly moving
to App Engine.
But this app, I think it's going
to be a huge win for us.
Because right now I still manage
this internal service
where this app is running.
This one, we actually offer
it for many, many
universities right now.
So we do expect a lot
of traffic on it.
MALE SPEAKER: I was
going to ask.
ALEX VAGIN: So we'll
be moving it on App
Engine for sure, yeah.
It's just not that
simple case.
There's many, many lines of
code already written.
But I do have already
some admin parts
running on App Engine.
And so we're basically calling
this Rails app through API,
extending JSON data.
MALE SPEAKER: How would you
authenticate the code between
your App Engine app
and your regs app?
ALEX VAGIN: Sorry?
MALE SPEAKER: How would you
authorize a code between your
regs app and your--?
ALEX VAGIN: Oh, right.
What I did--
but it's kind of secret.
But what it is--
I created a huge token.
I just didn't have time.
I created this huge
secret token.
And I basically put this
token into a header.
And this is how the Rails app
knows that this is kind of an
App Engine app.
And the interface
on App Engine--
I started using End
Points API.
I just got an invite.
So it's pretty cool.
MALE SPEAKER: But you
will be able to make
that more secure now.
ALEX VAGIN: Exactly.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So I have a few more questions,
if you don't mind.
So I would like to know what
is, in your opinion, the
greatest strength
of App Engine?
Like as a startup developer,
what motivates your decision
to go on App Engine or
to go somewhere else?
And if you have any suggestions
about how we
should improve the App Engine
developer experience or more
specific to request.
ALEX VAGIN: Well for
that I have a list.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
ALEX VAGIN: No, just kidding.
Well besides that, it
really auto-scales.
I think it was at the beginning
was the first thing
that I kind of noticed
that stood out
of all of the features.
And what I also like is that
there are so many services
around this platform, the user
services, whatever, a lot of
pipelining, a lot
of frameworks or
libraries around that.
So you basically can do
whatever you want.
But I remember back in 2009 or
8, what really impressed me is
when I started reading docs
about App Engine.
And I eventually got to this
task queue and [INAUDIBLE]
jobs.
And what I saw there is when you
actually create this task
queue or cron jobs
it call your URL.
And before that--
so basically before the App
Engine, what I was doing
usually is that I would have a
cron jobs on Linux server.
Or I could have ready server.
And I could have background
processes.
But still, they would execute.
I would still need to launch
some of these background
process instances.
And when I saw this, and
I was like, whoa.
So everything could be a URL.
So you can call you
application,
even for cron jobs.
That was awesome.
I really liked that.
I was interested.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So model of App Engine
is really
based on URL and requests.
And those can be a very short
request for front end or much
more request for test
queue on back end.
But I also like that the
[INAUDIBLE] is web based and
more HTTP based.
In the sense that everything
in App
Engine is an HTTP request.
And sometimes I think it was
difficult for people coming
from, for example, an RGS
background to easily
translate to that.
Because first, it's much more
like they have a process that
is spreading.
And these process has
dedicated memory.
And it's processing
a lot of requests.
But they don't think about
everything as an HTTP request.
They don't think about chunking
that processing into
an HTTP request.
I think that's a
big difference.
And that's one of the challenges
of adoption for App
Engine as well.
People are used to resident
process and resident memory.
And they come to App Engine.
And then their quota systems
[? start ?] and stop.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah.
Right.
But when I realized this, it
simplified things so much.
I was so happy that I could--
MALE SPEAKER: It's a really
easy model to put
your head around it.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Like
[INAUDIBLE].
AMY: Yeah.
When I first learned App Engine,
task queues were my
favorite thing too.
It's so powerful, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
is there any project
that you are not
choosing App Engine for?
Is there [INAUDIBLE]
you [INAUDIBLE] and
you say, OK.
I can't do that on App Engine.
I will just use a dedicated
server?
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah.
Well from my experience, today,
off the top of my head,
there is one thing that
I still can't
figure out how to do.
So it actually started when
I got my laptop broken.
And I had a couple of last
days' work on it.
And I couldn't get to it.
And I was thinking, well,
couldn't I just all do it on
the web, just programming?
So you have Chromebooks,
right?
So you have Google
Docs, right?
Whatever happens to your
hardware, it doesn't matter.
So I was thinking, well,
wouldn't it be great.
So what it is, I created this
just simple app where I could
edit the code with a browser.
I think I used CodeMirror
library.
But the thing that I wanted--
because I would be missing
that a lot--
is I also need to run tests.
And I also need to run
development depth server on my
localhost or whatever it is.
So for that, I think
I've made some--
I don't know.
I think Compute Engine would
be right for this thing.
MALE SPEAKER: You can just
use [INAUDIBLE].
ALEX VAGIN: Oh yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Like if you had
paging app, where you have
your [INAUDIBLE]
that is sending some Python
code into some data store
[? entities ?]
and executing on the fly, this
is the kind of setup that you
have to have some kind
of online [INAUDIBLE]
experience.
You can have a special version
for editing and then just more
stuff to a different version
once you want to [INAUDIBLE].
ALEX VAGIN: Right, right.
Yeah.
That's my point.
MALE SPEAKER: But that's only
possible for Python, though.
Because [INAUDIBLE]
conduit for [INAUDIBLE]
or Java.
But there is someone on the
development team that has made
an experiment where he has been
able to run App [? CAG ?]
on App Engine.
ALEX VAGIN: Cool.
Oh, wow.
MALE SPEAKER: Which
is [INAUDIBLE].
So it's Daniel on the
[INAUDIBLE] team who has
manged to deploy an App Engine
app from App Engine.
ALEX VAGIN: Whoa, whoa.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
MALE SPEAKER: It's
very, very nice.
And another way to do it
is that you could also
[INAUDIBLE]
Google Drive for that.
So you could have your
App Engine app.
Instead of providing
an [INAUDIBLE]
that is inside the app, you
could have the app fetch a
file on Google Drive
and execute it.
AMY: I just pasted into
this chat window.
There's an interesting blog post
that just came out that
this lets you run tests and then
deploy from, say, your
github repo.
MALE SPEAKER: And there is also
an online meter called
Code [INAUDIBLE] that allows you
to deploy to App Engine on
their platform and from there.
I think you're right.
There is not only one solution
for doing this.
And there is a lot of different
approach and
different acts that try to
achieve the same thing.
But hopefully, I hope that they
will converge [INAUDIBLE]
into the more [INAUDIBLE]
solutions, so people could just
[INAUDIBLE] in the cloud
instead of--
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
That would be awesome.
MALE SPEAKER: And do you have
any other suggestions for
improving App Engine [INAUDIBLE]
experience, or a
more specific future request,
your [INAUDIBLE]
your [INAUDIBLE] list?
AMY: What are the things
that are painful?
We want to hear them.
ALEX VAGIN: No.
I knew you'd ask me this.
So I prepared beforehand.
What I want to say, first off,
is recently you guys are doing
an awesome job at supporting
folks even on the forum.
I see replies flying all the
time, like almost to any post
on the forum.
I think it was one of
the missing things,
like to just support.
But really, yeah.
It's great.
Well, about the features, the
one thing that I remember is
at some point there was a
monitoring API for apps
running on App Engine.
And I think it kind of
stuck at some point.
And I know you guys are probably
working on some
improvements to that.
And well, there's
just this thing.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I think that Amy knows
more about this.
Because she's based in Sydney,
where the original team was
working on it.
I think that they have got
some feedback from the
[INAUDIBLE].
And they have got a
lot of feedback.
And they are trying to move
the project in a different
direction based on
this feedback.
But maybe Amy has
more insight.
AMY: No.
That's a good summary of it.
ALEX VAGIN: And then this
is actually, I've been
thinking a lot about.
This is actually kind of
related to the simple
authentication.
It's about the users API.
So right now, users API-- they
support four things.
You guys support Google
accounts, right?
So it's, I think,
Google accounts.
Or I could also do OpenID
authentication.
But the thing is, I'm not even
sure if it's a good idea.
But like the way
OpenID works--
so I could authenticate
any user with the
external OpenID provider.
I think it would be nice to be
able to do the same thing, but
not only using OpenID but OAuth2
or any other kind of
authentication.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I totally agree with that.
And so there is something really
frustrating when you
are using OAuth on App Engine
right now is that if you want
to have user SO authentication
and authorization with OAuth2
at the same times, basically,
you have to [INAUDIBLE].
So when the [INAUDIBLE] login
serves the App Engine requires
permission using Google
authorization, a mechanism to
share his email address
with the
applications, that's one screen.
And then, when you want to get
permission for Google Drive or
Spreadsheet API or Google
[INAUDIBLE]
API, [INAUDIBLE]
run screen for this
permission.
And currently, the only way mix
the two is to ditch the
standard authentication from App
Engine, and instead rely
on the user scope like you do
in Simpleauth in order to
authenticate the user.
And so then you can finally
request [INAUDIBLE].
You can say I want the email
address using the user
[INAUDIBLE].
And I also want to be able to
read his Drive [INAUDIBLE].
And I would really like if there
was a building way with
the user API to do basically
what you are doing now for
authentication using the user
API, but using the auth scope
user info and plus request an
additional set of scopes.
So you can reduce the ground
screen to only one.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
Exactly that, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: But I think you
did a very good job with
Simpleauth.
We can talk more about it later
on that kind of provide
the same solution with
the user [? end ?].
But it's a good inspiration
for the team to be able to
[? transfer ?]
that and offer that
as an active API.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, yeah.
Great, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So I would like to continue
with more questions.
I think we still
have some time.
So I would like to know more
about what your day to day App
Engine development looks
like, like what
editor you are using.
Are you using an ID?
Which language do you target--
Python, Java, [INAUDIBLE]?
And if you have a favorite App
Engine framework library or
[? tool? ?]
ALEX VAGIN: So actually
I like experimenting
with different IDs.
So I tried like a couple
of dozen of them.
But I used to use TextMate
all the time.
But then recently, I switched
to Sublime Text.
AMY: Me too.
ALEX VAGIN: But like I said
before, the best thing would
be if I had some web ID where I
could do all the same things
that I do on my [? common ?]
line terminal and Sublime.
But today I'm using
Sublime Text.
So I'm mostly using Python.
And I do experiment a lot
with Go these days.
And I was just reading recent
updates on Gorilla Web.
I think probably you were
working on that
with Rodrigo maybe.
MALE SPEAKER: I know
of just one thing.
But [INAUDIBLE]
to Go library was Go Auth2.
So you might be interested
by it too.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: But [INAUDIBLE]
Go Auth2--
I mean it's a nice library,
does the job.
But I think that there is some
room from improvement to make
it work better with
App Engine.
Especially, there is not a good
story yet for selling a
token to the [INAUDIBLE]
store.
You can go it by hand, but it
would be nice if there was an
integrated way to save
tokens [INAUDIBLE]
always goes to.
ALEX VAGIN: Right,
right, right.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
what [? Rodriguez ?]
has done with Gorilla.
And it's very nice.
I really like the [INAUDIBLE]
architecture, in the sense that
you can [? attack ?] any
part of it within the dragging
the [INAUDIBLE] thing.
So I like the component approach
that shows instead of
a big full stack framework.
He has this set of components
that you can use.
He's been also very active on
making the templates Go
support and [INAUDIBLE].
Because that's something
that's it's
really attached to.
And the story from
Go templates--
you can code [INAUDIBLE]
templates from other templates.
And you can [INAUDIBLE]
a composition.
But you still have to wire all
the templates together in your
code and that's something
that we're [INAUDIBLE]
in [INAUDIBLE].
So he is actively working
on this too.
ALEX VAGIN: Right.
Cool.
Yeah, that's awesome.
MALE SPEAKER: I like the
Go runtime a lot.
I don't know if you've
compared the
performance with Python.
But it's really interesting.
And also what I think about
the Go runtime is that it
gives you basically the same
interaction process that you
have when you are developing
Python, but just safer with
type and compiling Go.
What I like is that usually when
my Go app is compiling, I
know that it will work.
Whereas when I develop some
Python app, I still have to go
into each [INAUDIBLE]
code path to just know that I
did not make a syntax error.
ALEX VAGIN: Right,
right, right.
I was impressed when--
Oh, sorry.
Amy?
AMY: Oh no.
I was just going to say we were
thinking of having some
more Hangouts featuring Go.
So it sounds like you would
be in favor of that.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
Yeah, yeah.
AMY: Sorry.
Go ahead.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah.
I was impressed when I did try
Real Web and Go itself.
What I was impressed with--
the first thing, I wrote
Simple app.
And I launched in.
And it was super fast.
And it was like whoa.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I like the fact that Go, with
just using the storage QP
package, if you are not using
any of the Google App Engine
API, your Go app is still
a standard web app.
And you can run it wherever
you want and just compile
using the [INAUDIBLE]
package.
Because they are controlling the
language and the platform,
I like that they are really able
to get the two together.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, yeah.
Right.
Yeah, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And do you
have any favorite?
I mean, you were mentioning
Python before.
Do you have any favorite App
Engine framework for Python,
any libraries that you always
use in every app?
ALEX VAGIN: Oh, yeah.
Well, the first thing that I
just love is this NDBD--
the new DB interface.
So I like it.
Especially what I like is
the asynchronous API.
And this task list--
this is great.
And also Appstats is a tool that
I couldn't live without.
Appstats is something that
helps me every day.
And then what I also like
is also EReporter.
It's a package that whenever you
have some errors, it can
make your app email you
these exceptions.
So let's say you are running
a production application.
Instead of maybe monitoring the
log files, you can also
set it up so that you would
get notifications by email
when something goes wrong.
So I like that.
And then Back Loader
actually helped me.
I logged in.
Pushing some legacy data
into data store.
MALE SPEAKER: I think that the
exporting and importing data
story is getting better and
better, especially since we
introduced backups to Google
storage and restore.
Not a lot of people
knows this.
But if you go to the Google
App Engine project on
code.google.com, and you just
look at the SDK sources, the
sources for the backup and
restore administration
[INAUDIBLE]
is actually there.
So you can actually look
how this feature works.
And you can easily modify it
to support importing stuff
from test or that doesn't come
from backup, or writing NTGs
that come from your app and
export them to Google store
and [INAUDIBLE].
But I that the framework into
there is a solid base where
people can give their
own important
exporting mechanism on.
It's not well known that it's
open source in the SDK code.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah.
It's a great addition.
Yeah, definitely.
MALE SPEAKER: You mentioned
the Pipeline API before?
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah.
I forgot.
Yeah.
That's another thing.
I think I put it on my
favorites list, yeah.
I used it a couple
times, yeah.
Even if you had terabytes of
data, what I like about it is
that way, using Pipeline API,
you can process a huge amount
of data, and just not worry
about it later on.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So you mentioned both
NBD and Pipeline.
And there is something special
about those two libraries,
that they are not developed
inside the SDK lab.
They have their own project
on code.google.com.
They have [INAUDIBLE]
their online list.
They have their own [INAUDIBLE]
trackers.
And they get syncing to the
SDK on each release.
But I was wondering what you
prefer as a developer.
Like do you prefer that they
are structured as an
independent project?
Or do you prefer that everything
gets tracked into
the same App Engine product?
ALEX VAGIN: I don't know.
I like the way the NDB--
the fact that it has its own
Google group, forum, where I
think it's because there
could be a lot of
questions related to that.
So I think that way people
can track or ask
kind of specific questions.
And I don't really mind
to do import from
GoogleAppEngine.ext import
NDB instead of--
so I like the way
it is right now.
But I like the fact
that [INAUDIBLE]
back actions SDK.
But I also like the fact that
they have their own community.
And I think it's important for
the community to build and
[INAUDIBLE]
around [INAUDIBLE].
I wish we were doing the same,
for example, for [INAUDIBLE]
backup and restore thing, like
if it was the right project,
we could get contributions
more easily.
It will raise knowledge
that this is there and
people can use it.
Even though it's [INAUDIBLE]
inside the SDK.
But I think that it will deserve
more visibility.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, exactly.
And then plus there might be
some time when you could even
use those external projects
in some non-App
Engine related thing.
You could just take that call,
then communicate your needs
and just use it.
So, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: I think there is
only maybe 15 minutes left.
So I will try to ask
my question.
There's a last question
for you.
AMY: Do you think we should
just switch to demoing?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I think that we just have
one last section
before we get his demo.
And I think that we are fine.
Like do you have any tips?
You mentioned test queue.
You mentioned using
the background.
You mentioned at
the [INAUDIBLE]
you mentioned caching.
Do you have any user tips that
you would like to share with
an App Engine developer?
ALEX VAGIN: Sure, yes.
One thing is testing.
There is nice test
bed framework.
And I would have had to write
so much code to support my
testing environment.
So this has really
helped me out.
And the second thing
is code reviews.
If you are working on some open
source project, I think
it's codereview.appspot.com.
I think it's awesome to get
feedback from other
developers.
And actually when I was in
there, I was working on the
Simple app, there was this
guy, Eric Higgins.
I don't know if you
guys know him.
I think he's ex-Google maybe.
So I posted the link
to Go code review.
And I just said whoever feels
like code reviewing.
And suddenly I got it
reviewed this guy.
And it was awesome.
He gave me so much.
Like different people see
things from different
perspectives.
So it really helps
in development.
MALE SPEAKER: The Go project
is using code review
intensively for the
development of Go.
They have [INAUDIBLE]
called [? golden ?] dev, where
you can see all of the
contributions [INAUDIBLE].
And maybe that's something
we missed for App Engine.
Maybe we should have
[INAUDIBLE]
mailing list, where all the
community projects that are
also third party libraries that
are using App Engine and
building stuff staff can
submit code review.
So you can just watch it and
interact with people who are
developing App Engine apps.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah.
That would be great.
Yeah, yeah.
AMY: Incidentally, big props to
Guido, who is involved with
code review and app stats
as well as NDBs.
ALEX VAGIN: Right.
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And this one last thing that I
want to maybe emphasize is
I've seen a lot of blog
reports on App
Engine issue tracker.
And what I found out
myself too--
because I've been on
the other side--
when you file a bug report,
before submitting it, try to
put yourself on the other side
of the guy who is going to
handle this bug report.
And try to read what
you just wrote.
And try to figure out whether
the guy that's on the other
side will actually understand
what's going on.
Even better, if you
could submit a
patch, how to fix your--
because I've been there.
And I know a lot of bug reports,
when you get this
saying, it's not working.
And you just don't know
what to do with it.
MALE SPEAKER: I've been doing
a lot of work on the issue
tracker [INAUDIBLE]
[INAUDIBLE] who try to reuse a
[INAUDIBLE] of issues that we
have to triage.
There are some things that if
you can submit the test that
is reproducing the failure that
you are reporting, that's
a [INAUDIBLE] platform.
Because something that is really
difficult to evaluate
is how much time it will
take for you to
reproduce the issue.
And a test is basically the
reporter transferring to the
one who is going to
triage [INAUDIBLE]
the knowledge of what you
need to do in order
to reproduce it.
I think it's very [INAUDIBLE].
And we should have a better
story for people crashing
tests that are using test
bed [INAUDIBLE]
or that are [INAUDIBLE]
SDK in order to reproduce
a given bug.
But that's something that is
very valuable to an engineer,
when they have a simpler way
to reproduce a problem.
And you write about the issue
tracker, that people should
really to try to do
better submission.
But that's something also that
is on your plate as well.
We should try to improve and
to give more incentive to
people to do better
submissions.
Like for example, the submission
templates--
I am in the process of
refactoring them.
So it will better spell out what
you need to do in order
to submit an issue.
Because is it not always clear
to people that they first have
to describe the step to
reproduce the issues.
They have to describe what
they are expecting and to
describe what they
are seeing still.
And just listing that in the
template would, in my opinion,
raise the clarity of the issues
that we get reported.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, right.
Cool.
MALE SPEAKER: I heard that you
maintain a library which is
called Simpleauth.
So maybe you can talk
a bit about it.
And maybe you have a small
demo of how to use it.
ALEX VAGIN: Sure, yeah.
So you know what?
I'm going to just do a
little quick demo.
And I'm going to do
a screen sharing.
Oh, wait.
I'm going to share my desktop.
So do you guys see my screen?
Cool.
Yeah.
So yeah.
You can find the link to this
project on the Hangout
description, I think.
Well first off, just one minute,
where we all started.
So there was this website
where the [INAUDIBLE].
And what I needed to do is we
went to invite these PhD
school alumni.
We wanted them to RSVP if
they're coming or not.
The thing is, they are spread
all over the world.
So we didn't even know whether
they were using some social
networks like Google+ or
LinkedIn or whatever.
So what I thought is I would
just put these three buttons.
And whenever a guy coming in.
And they can just confirm it
with their preferred account.
So this is where
it all started.
And I just took this
piece of code.
And I put it into
the Simpleauth.
So how I can get started is
you can go to the source
through the check out base.
And you can copy the link.
And then you call it.
Make it a bigger screen.
So you call it.
I'm opening my header.
And so you have this example
application.
This is secrets.pi.template.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to copy the content of
this file in another one that
I just called secrets.pi.
So it's the same file
only without
top template extension.
And in here I have client keys
and the consumer key and
secrets for different
providers.
So I'm going to go and start
with Google APIs.
You'll find links to where to
get a client secrets on the
home page of the project.
Here is one for Google APIs.
So I'm going to go here.
And this is Google
API's console.
And I'm just going to
create a project.
And it's called hangoutdemo.
AMY: And you might make
your browser font
just a little bigger.
ALEX VAGIN: Sorry.
OK.
So there is nothing I
need to enable here.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to create an auth client
that's called demo.
Here I need to choose
a web application.
And what I'm going to do is--
well.
Let's say localhost.
Because I'm running
on a localhost.
Note the redirect URL.
We'll need to change it
just here in a second.
So here we go.
I get the client ID.
And I get client secret.
What I need to do, though,
is change this
redirect URL or callback.
I can either change this or I
could even add another one to
Google callback.
This URL--
If you go through the Getting
Started page, you'll see why
it is and how it is
formed like this.
So let me change this
at Google callback.
So I'm just going to copy client
ID and client secret.
And I think it's started.
So I'm going to go in
on this example.
And I'm just going to run it.
Try to see if this works.
I'm going to go to
my localhost.
So this is actually exactly the
same application as you
would see on the
simpleauth.appspot.com.
And since I only put real
client ID and secrets on
Google API, so I'm just
going to go ahead
and try and log in.
And there we go.
Now it's requesting
permission.
This is what we probably
talked about before.
This comes from the scope
parameter that we
talked about before.
I'm going to go ahead
and allow access.
And there you go.
We have a number of data here.
So this is data and auth info.
This is what you get
inside this method.
And so what I do is I'll just
print it out on the page here.
And you can see this is
coming from Google+.
Well, actually Google
OAuth API.
So you have some user
profile data.
This is OAuth 2.0.
Access token is what you'd need
to interact with Google
APIs in this case.
And you have this
expiration date.
And this actually is the result
of interacting with
Google API using just
the access token.
And just for the demo, I'm
printing out here since the
Simpleauth uses whatever Web App
has already implemented.
So it uses Web App's session
and auth package.
So you already have the
session thing already
implemented for you.
So I don't think we have
too much time.
MALE SPEAKER: That was
a very nice demo.
For the [INAUDIBLE] coding and
getting everything more clean
at the first time.
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah.
And you can basically do the
same thing for Facebook,
Twitter, and any other
OAuth 2.2 or
OAuth 1 or OpenID providers.
You can do the same thing.
MALE SPEAKER: And are you
persisting user creation using
a Web App 2 session mechanism?
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And then it's up
to the user if you want to
persist the user in the database
to do it from the
call back, right?
ALEX VAGIN: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
So the Simpleauth actually--
it's not the real handler.
It's just kind of mixed in that
you can add to your real
[INAUDIBLE]
handler.
And what's happening outside of
auth request and response
is up to the developer.
So he can use a different
session back end.
So you can use any user
model that you want.
Like the example application
uses what's
default of Web App 2.
But you can use whatever
you want.
MALE SPEAKER: So I think
that's it for the demo.
So thanks a lot, Alex, for
answering our questions and
going for Simpleauth.
Is there anything you
want to add, Amy?
Or any question from
[INAUDIBLE].
I don't know if we
have the time.
AMY: Just for those who might
have tuned in part way
through, look at the event
description for a link to the
repository for this code.
It's really very nice.
ALEX VAGIN: Thanks, guys.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
thank you, Alex.
AMY: Thank you very much
for joining us.
MALE SPEAKER: Bye.
ALEX VAGIN: Thank you.
I want to say I hope I'll see
more Hangouts for the Go
runtime and stuff like that.
AMY: Oh, good.
I'm glad.
And we'll try to do more that
are convenient for the
Europeans too than we
have been in past.
ALEX VAGIN: Cool.
Cool.
Thanks.
AMY: Thank you.
Thanks so much for joining us.
ALEX VAGIN: All right.
Bye.
AMY: Bye-bye.